Ants have many more smell receptors
than other insects like aphids and fruit flies--
could these be the key to their social organization?
Researchers used CRISPR to
knockout a gene called “orco”--
known to be important for odor detection
These are the first transgenic ants ever made
Genetically modifying ants has been tough
Their eggs need care that is usually only
provided by other ants
The raider ants used in this study are special
because they reproduce parthenogenetically
- making almost exact copies of themselves
which saves the researchers having
to breed many generations of mutant ants
When researchers raised ants without the orco gene
they were less sensitive to odors
Normal ants hate the smell of permanent markers,
but the genetically modified ants didn’t seem to mind
Based on camera tracking,
the mutant ants didn’t follow other ants’ scent trails
And young mutants wander
instead of joining in normal nesting behavior
These results suggest that odor isn’t just important
for foraging and communicating
but also for the very social nature of these ants lives.